welcome back to CBS morning's The Drug
Enforcement Administration is fighting
an alarming jump in deadly overdoses
more than 107
000 Americans think about that number
for just a second died from overdoses
last year and two-thirds of them were
related to fentanyl that's an especially
Dangerous Drug now last month we showed
you a government warning about so-called
rainbow fentanyl which looks as you see
very much like candy it is being
marketed to young people Jeff begays
traveled to Colorado where the drug is
taking a terrible terrible toll
fentanyl killed him
fentanyl killed him Kimberly osterman's
son Max died from fentanyl poisoning
last year he excelled in sports and
academics but he also had an addiction
he struggled he had his demons fentanyl
poisonings in the state of Colorado have
become all too common and there is a
reason the drug comes to the U.S from
Mexico and the cartels realize that they
can use the interstates and highways in
Colorado to reach vast parts of the
country what you see piled up on the
hoods of these cars are the almost daily
seizures of the drug investigators
compare it to a faucet you just can't
shut off there's no shortage of work for
our Troopers Colonel Matthew Packard is
the chief of the Colorado State Patrol
the people that are selling fentanyl
they're they are profit driven
and that's it profit above all else and
they do not care
how many body bags are a result of Ben
Knoll is a synthetic opioid 50 times
more potent than heroin in 2021 Colorado
saw nearly 70 percent increase in fatal
fentanyl overdoses it does not look good
what is going on in Colorado well the
numbers are bad all over the nation when
I speak to my colleagues across the
country other U.S attorneys fentanyl
comes up in every conversation since
2019 the number of federal prosecutions
in Colorado related to fentanyl has more
than tripled but an increase in
prosecutions has not translated into a
decrease in the flow of drugs does that
mean
uh the approach has been a failure well
the approach is ongoing and the approach
is multi-dimensional there's a whole
piece of this
which probably deals with mental health
with addiction with demand
in this case the officers responding to
a fentanyl overdose knew exactly what to
do by administering Narcan it saved This
Woman's life I'm scared she wanted us to
conceal her identity
scared to death what do you want other
people to get from your story so many
people are dying no one knows what
they're taking anymore
and even if they do
they're still willing to risk it and
it's not going to end well it's killing
our kids monster men will never get over
the loss of her son he thought he
had it all under control he thought he
knew how to manage for CBS mornings Jeff
begay's Golden Colorado
is with eye-opening reporting